quand même un petit mot sur l'incident
gainsbourg whitney houston
les jeunes regardent fois vous l'avez
dit vous avez manqué de sang froid
aujourd'hui vous le vous le sauriez du
plateau aujourd'hui j'aurais demandé
s'excuser mais c'était du direct un ben
oui mais c'est vrai on en plus bon c'est
sacha distel je vais tout vous raconter
sacha distel était très lié à dire une
warwick qui tirent une grande chanteuse
black américaine qui était la tante de
la petite whitney et la tante a appelé
distel en disant écoute ma nièce qui est
en train de devenir une vedette très
importante vient en france et quelle
télé il faut qu'elle fasse et sasha lui
a dit qu'une seule il faut qu'elle fasse
sans elysées c'est un copain à moi qui
présente elle va être reçue
face aux oubliettes la suite vous
connaissez alors juste michel je me
demandais parce qu'on n'était pas dans
les coulisses nous après évidemment il
ya eu un débriefing qu'est ce que vous
vous êtes dit en débrief comme on dit et
puis est-ce que vous en avez reparlé
avec lui avec serge gainsbourg ben ça a
été un scandale mondial d'ailleurs cette
séquence là que vous voyez ce qui est le
buzz de ces 51 à sanaa la télévision
passe dans le monde entier il m'est
arrivé de me promener au cambodge de me
promener en israël de me promener en
angleterre et on me parle de ça ça passe
tout le temps c'était tellement énorme
énorme ce qui lui a sorti ben si
aujourd'hui j'aurais dit de s'excuser
j'étais tellement sidéré j'ai essayé de
traduire comme j'ai pu tout le monde le
suit virton souvient mais surtout il a
lu il dit dans l'extrait abandonné maï
maï dans sept joueurs qui lit mon micro
ne marche pas qu'est ce que j'aurais
aimé qu'ils marchent pas sas ça reste un
cauchemar pour moi cette séquence